les sorcières j'ai failli j'ai failli
être en retard elle devrait parce que je
suis venu en deux bus en deux non pas qu
en france on n'a pas de pétrole mais on
a des idées
alors j'ai troqué macho contre une
double on avait peut-être vu devant le
studio c'est une deux blancs tachés de
roue alors quand on dit qu'est ce que
vous avez comme voitures jugées unis de
voeux alors les gens sont surpris parce
qu'ils s'attendent à le voir il enrôle
sauce l'artiste
alors quand ils vont arriver en deux
ils sont déçus alors les réflexions des
gens tiens là la paire de boeufs du père
de haut sur mon passage les quolibets
les mamans à leurs petits enfants
si les bus qui passent cacher vos rouge
tablier alors les enfants sauve qui peut
parce qu'ils te veux ça pose des
problèmes
exemple un fil rouge une deux shows
s'arrête pas le but et bah forcément le
roux ça les excite alary fonce et quand
sévère
alors pour faire repartir une 2 me qui
broutent ça fait peur
cet après midi sur mon passage est un
irresponsable qui a crié suivait leboeuf
avait un talent qui ont suivi avec des
pancartes oui marc moreau rage pour
corser le tout il y avait une affiche de
la vache qui rit on ne sait pas ce qui
se passe dans la tête des voeux est-ce
qu'ils ont cru que la vache foot et 2
ils ont foncé dans le panneau tête
baissée et pour retenir une double parce
qu'un bug c'est comme un bulldozer
s'enfonce tout est encore un bulldozer
vous pouvez l'arrêter
vous n'avez qu'à couper l'arrivée
d'essence ya qu'à couper mets un boeuf
qu'est ce que voulait couper
il l'est déjà
vous dire parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
mime mes camarades si j'en ai fait
beaucoup depuis six saisons sa maison
qui ont un talent fou c'est vrai et puis
j'adore sont des gens qui sont qui
n'hésite pas à s'oublier pour être un
autre et c'est ce que je voudrais vous
dire c'est que quelquefois on dit qu'un
artiste sait tout faire
tu sais tout faire aujourd'hui c'est
tout fait admin c'est tout fait mais un
mime ne peut pas tout faire
un jour je devais me met quelqu'un qui
n'a rien à faire
c'est vrai j'ai rien pu faire parce que
ne rien faire
ça peut se dire mais ça ne peut pas se
faire et depuis je pouvais partir je ne
pouvais pas le faire parce que le
personnage qui n'avaient rien à faire en
plus n'avait rien à dire
le directeur avait bien spécifié il
m'avait surtout pensez bien ce que vous
avez à faire c'est à dire en fait penser
à rien et il avait ajouté surtout ne le
dit pas et je lui avais donné ma parole
de mines que je ne dirai rien
alors je suis en prix sur 7 comme ça
j'ai commencé à ne rien faire sans rien
dire ça à l'air de rien mais faut le
faire il suffit pas de le dire et près
d'auxerre en plus je ne faisais rien
plus les gens disaient qu'est ce qui
fait le pub n'est pas fou il voyait bien
faisait quelque chose mais comme c'était
rien ils se demandaient ce que j'étais
venu faire et les critiques dans la
salle voyez bien que je ne faisais rien
et que je le faisais bien et s'attendait
à plus et moi qui les gens ne faisait
rien je pouvais pas faire moins les gens
grâce à lui qu'il voyait rien ils ont
commencé à trouver à redire donc au
moins faire un geste
avoir un bon mouvement entre ce que
voyant moi j'ai fait le seul geste
pouvait se permettre
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à faire sans
qu'on dise il en fait trop j'ai fait un
geste d'impuissance
alors les gens dans la salle qu'est ce
qui dit alors là j'ai rompu le silence
j'ai dû mesdames et messieurs mais je
n'ai rien dit qu'est ce que j'avais dit
la clôture et un rideau
non seulement je paye un hymne à ne rien
faire il ne le fait pas mais en plus il
ne tient pas sa parole il parle il a dit
monsieur vous n'êtes même pas bons à
rien alors le lendemain dans la presse
quand android comme on dit les critiques
comme j'avais rien fait ils n'ont rien
dit mais en bien
c'est quelquefois on dit il ya des
choses qu'il ya des choses qu'on
n'explique pas les choses inexplicables
les choses que quand on n'ose pas parler
tellement elles sont étranges
il ya quelques vous je le redis côté il
ya quelques jours jean tracy je rentrais
chez moi et leur prouver qu'ils avaient
deux heures du matin
il y avait un brouillard un brouillard à
couper au couteau et un trou d'un coup
j'entends fils d'abraham fils d'abraham
comme j'étais tout seul je dis oui
chic et vous j'entends une voix
lointaine je suis jéhovah combien de
témoins
je vous écoute la voix me dit tu es bien
le fils d'abraham
j'ai entre autres je ne suis pas le seul
nous sommes tout un peuple avec le fils
d'abraham et la voix me dis justement
c'est un appel au peuple que je viens de
lancer j'ai pourquoi moi il n'est pas ce
qu'on a trouvé personne pour moi je
voudrais te mettre à l'épreuve comme
j'ai mis jadis ton père à l'épreuve
si le père de hausse et non le père
abraham
j'ai dit c'est cette histoire ancienne
iwuy temps souvient-il
j'ai les premiers à bram une descendance
innombrables des fils des petits fils
des arrières petits fils sont un peuple
à condition qu'ils me sacrifier à son
fils si je sais il n'a pas fait maison
parce qu'au dernier moment
ma main rues sombres je devais vous avez
eu un beau geste
sans ça je ne serais pas là alors elle
me dit voilà je voudrais tout soumettre
la même épreuve sacrifie moi ton fils
j'ai vous trompiez malgé pas d'enfants
at il dit c'est parce qu'on m'avait dit
enfin bas
edit ça fait rien sacrifier moi ta femme
jenny là d'accord gd faut que j'en parle
dit-il oui bien que c'est pour la bonne
cause
didier de vous sûr que ce soit la bonne
parce que déjà que j'ai épousé pour le
bon motif or c'était pas le bon mais de
toute façon au dernier moment
ma main retiendra-t-on bras j'ai dit
vous pouvez me signer un papier 10 qui
est aigri et aigri alors j'en ai parlé à
ma femme elle a très mal pris
ouais je puisse sacrifier pour toi c'est
en plus faut que j'me couples en quête
pour sa famille jeudi enfin comment tu
conduite sacrée promotion ou un fils de
famille devenir le père du peuple
las
elle a compris l a compris c'est elle
même car mais mon bras elle m'a dit
vas-y vas-y
elle m'a dit tu es sûr que tu es
derrière toi je sens son souffle alors
pourquoi ici tu es parce que je suis pas
sûr que sa main soit assez forte pour
retenir nombre
les mines me surveille
dans la neige jusque là le blizzard
blizzard blizzard moi j'ai dit bizarre
vous avez dit bizarre
tiens comme c'est bizarre j'arrive
devant la cour d'un igloo le tout à
l'igloo je frappe à la porte de l'igloo
vous avez déjà frappé la porte d'un
igloo re quand la neige est molle vous
allez braves qui passe au travers
à l'intérieur il ya l'esquimau un
primitif
quand il voit dépasser une maille entrée
j'entre atmosphère glaciale où puis-je
m'asseoir sur la banquise will paul pour
les 1000 à victor ses seins
de la part de la part de blizzard
bizarre bizarre
moi j'ai dit bizarre comme c'est bizarre
ainsi arrêté et est apte
vous avez du feu alors l'autre primitif
avec un glaçon dans chaque main miment
si l'on suit ça ne prend pas
effectivement ça n'a pas pris
heureusement que j'aime et un nul est
alors l'autre primitif et enyeama tiaret
vous allez faire fondre la maison vous
avez fait un trou dans la moquette
on a pas on se rend pas compte mais on
commet des petits forfaits qui sont
quand même qu'ils sont assez à ces
affreux j'ai écouté hier soir je suis
entré dans une auberge pour y dîner
alors sur la carte il avait marqué
poussins rôti j'ai commandé un poussin
rôti et j'ai lu a eu un petit poucet
s'est jamais eu un petit pour faire
c'est mignon à croquer ce qui nous donne
comme ça ça fait effet pas puis
et j'ai mangé dans mon gros gros ça va
et élus et toulon une dure à cuire
elle a vécu elle a fait son temps mais
petit poucet vient d'être en partie le
cas mais le film sortira 9
ah ça pour guère mieux parce que chaque
fois qu'on va se faire cuire un homme
c'est comme si on envoyait un peu ce un
circuit gras et qu'est ce qui fait de
vous un sell-off on est là on est prêt
si on y parvient on rit pas sûr parce
qu'il ya quand même ce dilemme se dit
même que chacun connaît
qu'est-ce qui fait l'oeuf c'est la poule
et qui est ce qui fait la pole si elle
est alors la question est qui a commencé
est ce le fut le père de la poule où la
poule la mère de l'oeuf
ça peut pas être le coq les coqs ne
pompe pas de quoi qu'ils aient pas de
poule sans eux sans eux les coqs
comme il n'ya pas de code sans l
essentiel les poules
ah oui alors oui vincent l elle va sans
elle y aurait pu n'écope des poules me
pousse à aimer ce serait tant mieux
parce que j'aurais mangé autant et bien
j'aurais mangé du vos vieux veuf en
gobant il a vécu même niveau j'avais
déjà vu une petite tête de veau
à la vinaigrette j'aurais mieux fait de
manger à 9,3 jeu comme on dit qui mange
un haussement un beauf
il faut bien rire
il faut bien rire un rire un peu à
propos du rire il faut tout même je vous
le dise parce que c'est important
à propos parce que le rire comme chacun
sait par le rire c'est une énergie
contenue qui y'a pas de quoi rire c'est
une énergie contenue qui se libèrent
rapidement bon et en se libérant elle
fait vibrer les musiques les plus
vulnérables les plus fragiles qui se
trouvent être des zygomatiques avait
exactement bravo monsieur dont elle a
supposé que les muscles fessiers et
bénéficie troy n'a pas l'effectif soit
plus vulnérables que les zygomatiques et
va en rire est comme ça vous voyez une
salle cuiry désopilant bush
un rire triste mais ça ferait oui enfin
riant aux éclats je vois pas très bien
quoi encore
on l'a échappé belle toulouse attention
nos ancêtres y est comme ça aux ancêtres
et préventif guerrier comme l'homme des
cavernes le rire caverneux noms et les
primitifs les primitifs
il rit je n'ai rien contre les primitifs
je n'ai rien contre les prévenus dès
qu'ils ont tout inventé
ils ont tout inventé la pire tai chi à
ce qu'ils inventent et la pierre taillée
un prix qui le feu qui réinvente et fera
imprimer qui s'était pris dans son
village
alors un jour il a pris le pire une dans
chaque main aux innocents les mains
pleines c'est un tout c'est fait des
étincelles
alors le chef un primitif ou chivu chef
primitif mais chef
tout d'abord il a vu que du feu c'est à
dire qu'elle a vu de la fumée mais comme
il ya pas de fumée sans feu
menadi aller chercher le sorcier hors
charges et curieux à chakri primitif
il ya eu des primitifs à l'époque et
rupture d un technicien rejaillissent
est innocent il a dit à lindsay revêt
refait devant le sorcier ce que tu nous
as fait alors les nôtres avec ses deux
petites pierres tirs et a refait petite
flambée sur le le sorcier a dit feu de
dieu
ça sent le roussi
il a joué avec les amulettes il faut le
brûler alors le chef adjoint quoi et
l'autre innocent il a dit avec ça il a
mis le feu au bûcher qu'on venait de
dresser pour lui alors autour du bus les
primitifs il s'appelle derrière par
terre alors la réflexion qu'il espère
enfin heureusement qu'il n'a pas inventé
la poudre
parce qu'en prix de leur nul aurait
fallu faire partie de sa peine derrière
plus fort que le zoo ça lui a durci les
fessiers le les fessiers sont lus moins
vulnérable que les zygomatiques
le rire lui est monté à la gorge et l'a
fait
il avait inventé le rire raconte la
lente et multi les primitifs ont en tout
cas montée de la roue la roue la roue
l'éguille le fusain c'est tout de même
un primitif qui le premier a dessiné sur
la paroi de la caverne bison futé avec
des flèches ou la vache qui rit tout
inventé des prix tous et moi moi moi qui
suis évoluer si quel jeu inventé voici
quand même parce que tout même
l'histoire telle que je viens de vous la
conter
c'est moi qui aie
on avait plus on rit plus comme avant
très écoutée en venant ici j'ai vu dans
la rue j'ai vu ce soir 1-1 type tu veux
un type choir et ça ne m'a pas fait rire
j'écoutais avant quand je voyais choir
un type jeunesse parfait et la situe
juste suffi pour lui dire ce que vous
vous êtes fait mal il faut dire qu'il
avait mal furent ils avaient de quoi
parce que maintenant les gens ne savent
plus voir quand tu joues à essoyes
triste je pense à pleuvoir et savent ça
sera rude mais bourgeois et sans prévoir
et j'imagine que ce soir c'est des
joueurs ce soir n'est pas des choix un
homme qui a chuté pas déçu à condition
qu'ils soient bien comme aisément paix
ou que tu shoah choix bien justement
père et sa fille sa fille charlie savait
ce que c'était que de choir il avait été
aux bus deux soirs de soirée dans un
chic sous un chapiteau
il avait pas mal fut dans la chute dans
les cieux et il y aurait voulu que je
sois mieux que lui art tout petit mzée
soirs comme ça de ses genoux diversité
hachoir les chemins fois mon show dans
la sciure qu'est-ce qui la culture poire
non seulement une fusée choir chez moi
mais il m'en voyez choir chez les autres
et à ses parents soient mal chez les
autres mais on doit mieux chez soi même
parce qu'on choix sans retenue on se
rend parfois on est chez les fous
d'avant le choix font mettre des gants
permettez que je sois ici boum ou bien
préférer bon je sois labeaume
alors quand on a toujours su dans la
chute dans la sueur et que soudainement
il faut se parfaire le tapis en france
soit pas dans son élément ont chois plus
look son haut rang alors la réflexion où
il manque de savoir choix vous avez vu
comme il lâché ma chère oui parce que
dans un certain milieu
parce que dans certains milieux choir ça
s'apprend et les cours du soir je suis
allé vous apprennent à choir en trois
soirs alors vous avez le pressoir
d'ailleurs ces instants qui précèdent
dans mon bureau choix bon alors vous
avez le choix proprement dit parlant en
soi on peut pas le choix bon et une fois
que vous avez là pressoir moi j'ai eu
des après soir difficile parce que oui
même plus m'asseoir
alors comment vous de trois choix
enchaîné toujours pas fichu de bien
choisir les sujets légers c'est tombé
sur mon père en sortant mon père me dit
mondial échoue un peu devant moi que je
vois aux tournées sur le plan choir bon
enfin je n'étais pas chaud enfin je le
choix c'est pas que tu sois mal mais
touche warhead une des choix sauf fois
soit comme le char lire garde un chat
soirée choix comme lui tu joueras bien
parce qu'un chat un chat un chat ses
choix un chien aussi un chien aussi ses
formes est moins bien qu'un chat à qui
un jour j'ai vu un chat choix sur un
chien chien au choix un petit chouchou
qui co après une poule qui faisait
croire d'un perchoir avait réfuté tout
un concours de circonstances a fait
reprendre et c'est à dire que la poule
avait vu soir un mouchoir d'un séchoir à
fort elle avait chuté en fin de l été
père chez le chiot voyons la poule soir
c'est elle en cherche à prochain achat
pour sa poursuite
alors attendez plus souhaité la chute
est alors le chu a su un film le chat
sur le chiot s'est de nouveau et bien
mais bel et bien le chouchou a moins
bien je suis sûr que le cha cha jiji
je vous fais une petite sonnerie
l'attaquent l'attaquent chaque fois que
je sonne la taille france à mon grand
père parce que mon grand-père a rendu
son dernier souffle sur le champ de
bataille
s'il vous plaît il sonne l attaque est
l'ennemi attaque et alors il a pris un
boulet dans le pavillon il a avalé
l'embouchure ça pardonne pas alors quand
on a rapporté son clairon à sa veuve
elle a dit oui quelle idée aussi d'aller
faire de la musique dans un moment
pareil je ne se rendait pas compte
alors mon père a repris le flambeau mais
flambeau parce que nous sommes tous
clairon de père en fils et mon père a
fait toutes les guerres en tant que
clermont d'ailleurs pour mon père la
guerre c'était une belle sonnerie il les
a tout fait
il a sonné toutes les attaques de la
guerre 14-18 et toutes les retraites de
la guerre 39 40
et les morts à la retraite d'une attaque
dans son livre le destin
il faut pas se tromper de sonneries
parce que la sonnerie et sonneries mon
exemple ouvrez le ban fermez le ban
c'est la même chose alors le soldat qui
n'a pas obtenu qu on ouvrait le banc
quand on ferme y croient qu'on loue et
il attendre anciens alors quand on ouvre
un nouveau tu crois que cela fermeture
et ralph est lui passé comme ça confie
reléguait rejettera d'ailleurs lui
créant pardonnez moi l'expression ils
sont tous un peu sonné moi mon voisin
c'est mon professeur de clairon en plus
déjà pendant la guerre il était porte
drapeau il a tellement pris l'habitude
de brandir un drapeau que depuis qu'il a
plus de drapeaux il brandit plus dit il
est épuisé parce que non qui m'ont déplu
et métayers alors quelques fois
j'entends sa femme qui a eu bris qui lui
crée des brandi autre chose
non c'est un drapeau rien elle écrit
accroche un drap blanc au bout d'un
manche à balai et brandi leurs lui
capituler le ramed
il entend parce qu'ils jouent il n'a pas
d'oreilles alors qu'antti quand ils
donnent une leçon quand ils jouent ça
donne ça dit voulez vous prêter une
oreille attentive parce qu'il paraît
quand on prête l'oreille on entend dieu
enfin c'est faux c'est la faulx il m'est
arrivé de prêter l'oreille d'un sourd il
entend mais pas bien parce que vous avez
les phrases toutes faites comme ça
allait frac j louis guilloux qui avait
des choses qui est entré par une oreille
qui ressortait par l'eau non mais
franchement je n'ai jamais rien vu entré
par une oreille et encore moins à en
sortir il ya qu'en littérature course à
filament de rabelais dans rabelais nous
lisons que garda mail amilcar quand tu
as au monde parlant et gauche parce
qu'il sous-entend que par l'oreille
droite
il va se passer des choses du temps
décrié des sucettes pas de quoi vous
faire dresser l'oreille alors le ver
bouillir au présent ça fait jour jours
ci au lieu de dire j'entends jouer du
jour
les gens vont penser que ce que le
mandant et j'aurais eu alors que ce que
j'entends peut être particulièrement
triste
il faudrait préciser n'est ce pas dieu
que ce que joie et triste
joie tu vois mon chien qui aboie le soir
au fond des bois
jonnier iso assez bête loi voix et loi
loi ce que nous ayons l'eau al-watan
sérieux de dire le rayon dit louis louis
de loi oui pour te clos appartiennent à
louis alors louis de louis a oui ah oui
et karoui louis de loi de louis alaoui
ce que tous trois mois
et quoi toutefois et bientôt tu dois
avoir commencé à boire le soir au fond
des bois toutefois avoir whaou ont passé
ça fait joui joue il n'ya vraiment pas
quoi
ce qu'on m'a demandé de faire un
discours
je vous signale tout de suite où les
dames et messieurs que je vais parler
pour ne rien dire
je sais vous pensez s'il n'a rien à dire
ils feraient mieux de se taire g c'est
trop facile
c'est trop facile vous voudriez que je
fasse comme tous ceux qui n'ont rien à
dire et qu'ils gardent pour eux et bien
non mesdames et messieurs moi quand je
n'ai rien à dire je veux qu'on dise je
veux en faire profiter les autres et si
vous-même mesdames et messieurs vous
n'avez rien à dire eh bien on en parle
on en discute je ne suis pas ennemi du
colloque
mais me direz-vous si nous parlons pour
ne rien dire de quoi allons nous parler
d'un de rien de rien car rien j'ai paris
à la preuve assez complet soustraire
rien - rien égal moins que rien alors si
on peut trouver moins que rien c'est que
rien vous déjà quelque chose on peut
acheter quelque chose avec rien en
multipliant bon une fois rien c'est rien
deux fois rien c'est pour beaucoup
d'accord mais trois fois rien pour trois
fois rien on peut déjà acheter quelque
chose et pour pas cher
maintenant si vous multipliez trois fois
rien par trois fois rien rien x rien
galerie 1 3 x trop égale neuf ça fait
rien de neuf
non
alors choses par l'eau de toutes parts
en parlant de la situation ce n'est pas
nous la situation sans préciser laquelle
si vous le permettez je vais faire
brièvement l'historique de la situation
quelle qu'elle soit et quelques mois
souvenez vous la situation pour n'être
pas pire que celle d'aujourd'hui
n'étaient pas meilleurs non plus déjà
nous allions vers la catastrophe et nous
le savions nous en étions conscients car
il faudrait pas croire que le
responsable d'hier était plus ignorant
de la situation que le sont ceux
d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ce sont les mêmes oui la
catastrophe nous le pensions et est pour
demain et c'est à dire qu'en fait elle
devrait être pour aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
si mes calculs sont justes
or que voyons nous aujourd'hui qu'elle
est toujours pour demain
alors je vous pose même la question
mesdames et messieurs elle s'en
remettant toujours au lendemain la
catastrophe que nous pourrions faire le
jour même que nous les vitres on nous
signale entre parenthèses que si le
gouvernement actuel est pas capable
d'assumer la catastrophe
il est possible que l'opposition sont en
paix